the legality of marriage is very weird
because marriage the word means to mix
so like two people spending a lot of
time together mixing their energy are
essentially in a form of marriage
whether the law says it or not doesn't
really matter yeah so that's like a
common law marriage it's something like
seven years ago
oh in canada it's a lot shorter this is
gonna be wrong but it's two or three if
you're living in the same household in
ontario anyway and i'm pretty sure if
you split up after that if you've been
living together then you still have
court to deal with oh wow even though
you're not yeah what if you're just
roommates no no no you have to be in a
relationship like you have to do
whatever yeah but what if they say that
you are it's iffy i would assume that
that's still okay i mean when you're
filling out taxes and things you can put
yourself as common law so if you started
filling that in then maybe that might
screw you out over in the future but
it's short i think it's three years